guys are from Chicago, you're going to
know Bub City, it's closed down. Bub
City was a restaurant. It was located
close to Cababrini Green. If you want to
know Cababrini Green, Google Cabrini
Green in the 80s, 90s. It was the pits.
It was dangerous. Well, I started
working for the valet parking as a
security for the for the lot. So, you
know, when you go to a restaurant, you
have valet parking.
>> So, they would bring the cars, right?
and I'd watched a lot. Well, the doorman
for Bub City was a follower of the
Nation of Islam.
Now, remember guys, I know nothing about
Islam.
So, you know, right? You know that
Byzantine Vinus. Oh, you checked it out.
Yeah. I know nothing about Islam. So,
you guys know, right? Brings back
memories, right?
Yeah.
Nothing about Islam. All I know is I'm
looking at a African-American, right? A
black dude,
>> right?
>> And all I can hear him saying is,
"Praise be Almighty Allah." He's using
the term Allah. Kind of caught me off
guard because Allah. Wow, man. So, I
asked him, I said, "Hey, hey, buddy. Uh,
you know, you say Allah." It's
interesting because we say Allah. See,
this is where the Muslims catch you by
the videos. Hey, well, Jesus spoke
Aramaic. He said Allah. That's Allah.
You know what I'm saying? Yaki. How are
Yaki? sort of got my curiosity. So he
started talking about Islam.
He started talking about the honorable
Elijah Muhammad.
>> He started talking about the prophet
Muhammad. He started talking about
master Muhammad.
So I don't know who these people are.
And I'm thinking they're the same same
individual because look Muhammad
Muhammad Muhammad.
>> Yeah. the Honorable Elijah Muhammad,
Master Farad Muhammad, the Prophet
Muhammad. Well, I don't know who they
are. And he talks about Minister Lewis
Farrakhan. Now, if you guys want to know
what this movement is, Nation of Islam
is a pro black movement that uses Mus
Islam to liberate black people from the
white man and the Jew.
The Alaz. Look at I like this guy. The
Al. Okay. According to their myth,
Allah is a black man and the first
people that were produced are black
people and black people are all divine.
So Allah is a black man and he he
flies around in a UFO called the
mothership. This is part of their
teaching. Now I'm learning this way
later. At this time I have no idea what
he's talking about. So Allah black man,
there's a council of elders. They're all
black people, you know, the 24 elders of
Revelation,
>> right?
>> They fly around in a UFO called the
mothership, right? And Allah created
black people to be gods, but there was a
mad scientist named Yakub.
Yakub
>> Jacob
>> who? Yeah. Well, their myth is not
completely identical with the Jacob of
biblical history, but mad scientist
named Yak who rebelled against the gods.
So he got punished. So out of revenge,
what did he do? He said he's going to
create a race that's going to be a thorn
in the side of the black man. A race
that's going to oppose and try to
subjugate the black man. So he set in
rules because suppose he was a scientist
and knew about genetics. And so
according to this myth, the recessive
gene, see each one of us have a
recessive gene, a weaker gene,
>> right?
>> So they said, well, what's the recessive
gene for black? I believe it's brown.
What's the recessive gene of brown? Red.
What's the recessive gene of red?
Yellow. What's the recessive gene of
red? Yellow. White. So then he put in
motion
saying, "If you have a brown child,
honor it. That's an angelic child. But
if you have a black child, he had it
killed." So he set in motion where his
followers when they would have children,
if it's a brown child, they would honor
it. Black child, he would get it killed.
So then 200 years go by, now there is a
race of brown people.
So now, what's the recessive gene of
brown? They'll say red.
>> Red. So now when you have red children,
honor them, get rid of the brown
children. So then two more hundred years
red a red race produces and then yellow
and then white. The white man came into
being. According to their myth, the
white man was crawling on all fours like
a beast.
So Moses was sent to tame them. And this
is the white race that was produced to
try to destroy the black man. Now notice
the white men wore who? Who? Those whom
Moses sent to tame. In other words, the
Jews.
And so they believe the blondhaired,
blue-eyed man. And the Jew, they are the
devil race.
Now, this myth doesn't believe in an
afterlife and a resurrection. You just
live this life, you die. But eventually
Allah will come in his mothership and
he's going to zap and wipe out the white
man, the devil race, and the Jew.
This is what they believe. By the way,
guys, you go.
>> No, say I'm here. I'm here. Sorry.
>> By the way, guys, go Google me. See if
I'm lying to you. Now, according to the
myth, Allah, in order to save the black
people, had to infiltrate.
So Allah decided to show up in the 1930s
as a white man.
His name was
Wallace Ford.
As he was traveling in, by the way,
Michigan. Hey Calaldians, Michigan. He
found a man named Elijah Pool. Elijah
Pool. And he told Elijah Pool, "Let me
now, right? Let me now." Oh, so you got
it, too. Reveal to you the true origins
of the black man. And he told Elijah
Pool, I'm actually Allah. Don't let my
skin deceive you. I'm appearing in the
likeness of sinful flesh.
I'm appearing as the enemy to infiltrate
them in order to then reveal the secrets
to you. I am actually Allah and
supposedly his real name was
Master Farad Muhammad. I'm now going to
appoint you to be my prophet to lead the
black people out of their bondage to the
white man, the white devil. So his name
was changed to Elijah Kharim and then
eventually Elijah Muhammad and that's
where we get Malcolm X.
Malcolm X made them famous and then
Elijah Muhammad had Malcolm X murdered
when Malcolm X exposed this fraud. So
let me show you what Master Farad Muhamm
in fact one of the best biographies on
Malcolm X and this is all in the movie.
Get Spike Lee's movie Malcolm X because
in the beginning you're going to see a
picture of Elijah Muhammad and Master
Farard Muhammad but he looks like a
white man. So right here. So this is the
dude who's introducing me to Islam. Now
he didn't tell me all this. I went and
learned it on my own.
>> Yeah, I was going to ask. So you did
that on your own, right?
>> Yeah, because he just told me and I'm
like okay. But then I found out about
who? I found out about Malcolm X. So I
got his autobiography, right? His
autobio by Alex Haley. He's the one who
also wrote the fiction novel Roots.
>> Right.
>> Okay. Alex Haley based on this lie that
the original religion of the black man
was Islam and that the white Christians
came and deceived them.
Let me show you a picture of Master
Farra Muhammad. They still have it. Now
he disappeared. Some theories say that
Elijah Karim got him out of the picture.
I don't know. Master
Farad Muhammad. Here you go.
There you go. This is him right here.
This is him. See, he appears as a white
man. Why? Because he came in the
likeness of sinful flesh to infiltrate
to expose their plots to here Elijah
Muhammad.
Elijah Muhammad.
It's very interesting.
>> Yes, Muhammad Ali joined this cult.
But later on, Muhammad Ali, he became
Orthodox Sunni Muslim.
>> In fact, here's what's ironic. The son
of Elijah Muhammad,
Warith, I believe his name is Wedin
Muhammad, when his father died in 1975,
he became Orthodox Muslim and denounced
his father's fairy tale of Islam.
He actually basically a son, right?
Watin Muhammad, I believe it is, I'm
going to double check, pretty much
became Orthodox Sunni Muslim
virtually admitting my father was a
fraud and this version of Islam is a
lie. He became Orthodox Sunni Muslim.
But then who took over
took over the movement and continued the
lie of
Elijah Muhammad? Lewis Farrakhan.
>> Yes.
In other words, when Elijah Muhammad's
son pretty much came out and renounced
his father's Islam 195, look at it. When
he died, said, "We're going to be
Orthodox Sunni Muslims because that's
true Islam." Pretty much admitting my
father was a liar, con artist, because
this Islam is a lie. The movement would
have died. But Lewis Farrakhan stepped
up to the forefront and he said no. And
he continued it till this day. He's
still alive. Lewis Farrakott.
But how shameful
that your own son ends up apostatizing
and pretty much says this is all a lie.
This Islam is a lie. It's a joke. It
doesn't exist. And so he became Sunni
Muslim.
Let me find.
>> So all it took was that doorman or that
security dude to talk about Allah and
then you went into this on your own or
was he a Nation of Islam guy? No, he was
the Nation of Islam, but I didn't go
into it. I He introduced me and then I
went I asked for Quran. He gave me a
Quran.
>> I'm figuring this out later.
>> But I never became officially Muslim
because I obviously I'm not black. How
am I going to join Nation of Islam? But
>> right,
>> I didn't meet Sunni Muslims.
So I'm learning this on my own. This is
the son. What if what if Dean Muhammad
who came out and became Orthodox Sunni
Muslim
pretty much saying my dad is a fraud.
So this is my introduction to Islam.
This is my introduction to Islam. You
guys get it now?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So I know you're getting I want
everyone else to get it. So I still
don't know the difference. All I know is
he's telling me Master Farag Muhammad,
the Honorable Elijah Muhammad. Then I
read Malcolm X's biography and I was
floored by Malcolm X. I was amazed. This
man who was pretty much a criminal
supposedly had a vision. And here's
what's ironic. Part of his testimony
part of his testimony is that Elijah
Muhammad appeared to him in a vision
while he was in prison. Okay? And that
convinced him this is the truth. But
then later on he came out. He left the
Nation of Islam because Elijah Muhammad
was knocking up young girls, getting
them pregnant out of wedlock, signing
children,
and adulterous relationships. You know,
that's what caused Malcolm X to start
questioning Elijah Muhammad. It's all
document.
He started having sex with some of these
young, beautiful black women. He knocked
them up, got them pregnant out of
wedlock, pretty much adultery,
>> right? And so Elijah Muhammad pretty
much justified and said, "Well, hey,
look at Solomon. Solomon had seven
wives, not a concise, and I need to
spread my seed all over the world."
So then Malcolm X saw the gig is up.
This guy's a fraud. But then how do you
account for the vision? Malcolm X, he
said he had a vision of Elijah Muhammad
appearing to him in his cell. In his
cell. All right. Well, now what are you
going to say? Was that Satan who
appeared to you?
This is why I say be careful of basing
your faith on dreams and visions.
>> Right?
>> God will speak to people in dreams and
visions. But so can Satan
masquerade as an angel of light
>> and he can also do miracles and appear
in dreams and visions. Because here,
according to Malcolm X's own testimony,
in his prison cell, Elijah Muhammad
appeared in a vision in glorious light
and that convinced him this man is
Allah's prophet. But then later on, he's
the one who says, "No, the guy's a
fraud. He's a fake. He's a liar." So
then what did you see, Malcolm X? You
must have seen Satan
>> who appeared as Elijah Muhammad. So
anyway, he ended up leaving and he got
murdered because he was now calling them
out and he was exposing them. He got
murdered. Well, I got fascinated with
him. So that got me interested in Islam,
started reading the Quran.
>> So
>> let me ask you a question while you're
at that particular point. Is there
anything left in your mind about
Christianity
>> or is it completely foreign at this
point? you're fogged from that, you
know, side of things. And at this point,
you're enamored or you're infatuated
with what you're learning or reading
about the Nation of Islam and Mal Islam.
I'm reading the Quran now.
>> Okay. So, now we're outside of that.
Okay.
>> Yeah. Because I asked him for a Quran.
This is what the Quran did. It brought
me back to the Bible.
>> That's the best.
>> Now, I'll explain to you. Sorry, my
allergies. A damn the hair. Mom, take my
cat, bro. Please take my cat, man.
>> I have one. She's 11. Not only does the
cat kill me with the cat hair allergies.
When I leave town, I have to get a
catsitter. People think I have a money
tree. But anyway, see, look. Look at the
hair. Damn. Damn hair. That's probably a
genie appearing as cat hair. All right.
Now, coming back. So, I'm starting to
read the Quran. Here's what's important.
Why I tell you guys the Bible is true
when it says train up a child in the way
that he he should go, right? And it
won't leave him,
>> right?
>> Basically, remember my childhood? I got
saturated with the Bible, with Jesus
Christ, with the gospels. I was
saturated. So the foundation was there.
It was in my subconscious. So now notice
that foundation as a child,
>> it was there.
>> It was there. So if you train your
children now, you keep hammering,
planting seeds, and watering them, teach
them pray. Even if later on life, let's
say they fall away, that foundation is
now imprinted in their subconscious. And
the spirit will always be convicting
them and drawing that out of them and
reminding them because that's my story,
right?
>> So I started reading the Quran,
>> started reading the Quran, I was
flabbergasted. See again these damn
hairs. I was flabbergasted. Why?
Remember my family never told me about
Islam. See my family, my mom and dad
were biblically uneducated.
Biblically uneducated. All right.
So, they didn't give me any Christian
training, no kateesas because they
didn't know the faith,
>> nor did they tell me about Islam. So,
two strikes. Not only did they not share
with me about Christianity, they didn't
even tell me about Islam because they
came from Iraq and they came from
Kuwait, not a word. So, here I am in
America and I'm being a Jewish Islam and
I'm reading a Quran and I am shocked to
find the biblical characters in the
Quran. I was like amazed,
>> right?
>> What? What's going on here? I was really
baffled. There's another book that
actually mentions the prophets and Jesus
that I was raised on. Abraham, Isaac,
Jacob, Moses. So, I went to the index.
It was I believe in Abdullah Yusf Ali.
>> Okay. I don't know if I still have it in
my library. If it is, it will be with
Albi in Chicago. I don't know.
>> Anyway, I went to the index and I tried
to find all the references to Jesus and
I am shocked again. What in the world is
this book doing talking about Jesus,
right? And I'm I don't understand it,
>> right?
>> It's not like I'm reading it and I'm a
scholar. I'm just shocked. What's Jesus
doing in here?
So that put a curiosity in me to go back
to my roots. What were my roots?
>> King James.
>> Oh yes.
>> What was my roots? Baptist theology.
What was my roots? Christianity. And
part of my root which I mentioned in
previous sessions that grandmother,
she taught me the love for the holy
mother because she taught us to pray and
she taught us this these prayers that I
still remember like yesterday. They
never leave me.
But the last word I could never know how
to pronounce it. You know that's the
holy
holy is God.
I think means the holy immortal.
>> Yeah. Holy God. Holy mighty one. Holy
immortal.
>> Yes. That's in the liturgy. Anyway, she
taught me that. But then then she taught
me this as a kid. She'd meet there and
she'd teach us these prayers. And he has
in his library the audio cassette where
she's recording me as a child praying
those prayers. She He has it. She went
on to be with the Lord. He has the
cassette. He told me I have the audio
cassette where him and I, me six and a
half and him around nine, you'll hear us
praying. Now, I've never heard it. I
would I wish he would convert it so I
can hear what my voice sound like as a
child. Now, the other thing she taught
me, she taught me this form of the a
Maria. A
a
maria
that form she taught me.
So seeds are planted.
Even when I was in my Protestant days,
that seed that was planted always gave
me a connection to the Holy Mother.
That's why if you guys go watch my Jesus
or Muhammad days when I'm with David
Wood, you'll hear me say the blessed
mother of our Lord, the mother of my
Lord. Even back then,
>> right,
>> we're planted because obviously now we
know the saints are alive. Our holy
mother is alive. She loves us. She prays
for us. That I have no doubt.
>> Right?
>> That means she never stopped praying for
me. And that's why I could not forget
her. I could not forget her. Right?
Because I I know by the grace of God
hearing that six and a halfyear-old
saying the a Maria when I said it
obviously the saints are aware of what
we do on earth by the grace of God. What
God wants them to know he will make
known to them by the spirit. So I do
believe as I said that that the holy
mother heard the prayer of that young
child and she kept me in her heart.
See that's why I'm very zealous for her.
Now she needs me. She's she has God as
her son. She doesn't need me. And that's
why I get very angry and animated when
people insult her. Very angry. Very
animated.
>> In fact, if it was a face to face, I'll
probably be in a hospital or in jail.
This really because it's personal for
me.
>> Okay. So as I read the Quran,
started reading the New Testament, I
fell in love with Jesus all all over
again. I fell in love with him. In fact,
I remember the night I fell on my knees
in tears and I basically said, see these
stories are kind of get me very
emotional. And one reason why I hesitate
to want to get emotional because we got
people who hate us and despise us,
>> right?
>> And want to slander us. Look at he's
fake. Look at he's fake. Look, he's Hey,
buddy. You can think I'm fake all you
want. May God save me from my own
arrogance.
>> Right.
>> But I do get emotional thinking of how
God has been good to me and he's still
good to me and I'm garbage. Like Paul
would say Philippians 3:8, I'm
>> Right.
>> Yeah. Honestly, I am And I don't
pray to pretend to be holy. I want to
be. That's why I said don't make me more
than I am. But I remember that night as
I read the Gospels, I fell in love with
Jesus again. I was falling in love. I
go, "Wow." I had missed the Lord,
>> right? All those years I lived without
his words in my ears.
So when I started reading his words
again, man, I fell in love. And I
remember I was in tears and I remember
saying, "Woo!" I said, "Lord,
I'll come back home."
I remember saying